Hello
and welcome everyone to Active Flab.
Today is May six, 2021,
and we're really excited
to have Shawna Dobson
back for Math Stream 2.1.
This is going to be a fun discussion.
Diamond Holographic Principle
and D Square Emergent Time.
Maybe you'll teach us how to pronounce it
and what it is.
So thanks again for coming on the stream
and really looking forward to it.
So please take it away.
Thank you so much. Daniel.
I just want to say
your community is so supportive
and I'm so happy to be back for a second
talk.
You are all working on
some of the most profound ideas
here, and so I'm really excited.
And thank you for having me. Yeah.
All right.
So this talk, I'm
going to go a little bit into
the more like the diamond part
because I got some feedback
on one of these diamonds.
What was she talking about?
And so I was really excited
that these squares actually d
diamond for emergent time.
So if I I'll try to do my best
to lay all these out.
Please ask.
Like, Daniel was saying questions every,
you know, ten slides or something
like that.
I'm happy to answer it.
I'm also trying to concentrate
and weave together this sort of
kind of grand unified picture.
So there's some drawings in here,
and I hope that it's fun.
OK, so let's let's go.
I'll be talking
about the diamond holographic principle.
And did Diamond emerge in time?
Yeah.
OK, so the goal I sort of talked about
this last time, but not to too in detail.
Today, I'm actually weave together
this kind of new math
with active inference and let's
try to put it together
and all work together.
So the goal is like to take
the holographic principle, which we're
all aware of,
which was like begotten by design as
beautiful gage gravity duality
between entities that are office space
and conformal field theory.
I have an idea to sort of reinterpret
it in terms of continuous case theory
and something
I'm going to call pro emergence.
So a pro object is a specific object
kind of an category theory
that's being used everywhere.
And it's sort of this idea
of sewing together a bunch of
kind of smaller things
that are self-contained
to get a grand object and it's sort of
built into the very structure.
I thought, Oh, this is a great idea.
So I talked about case theory
a little bit last time,
which is this beautiful construction
by Growthand to actually look at
classifying very difficult objects
using Isomorphism classes of the spaces.
So it's like, oh,
we can tell if two spaces are equivalent
based on their equivalence relations.
And I thought that's a very, very, very
nice higher way of looking at things.
And there's new work by them off
talking about continuous case theory.
So again,
this idea of sort of sewing together
maybe smaller case areas
to build a bigger object.
So for this pro emergence, right,
I am fascinated by time
and I want us to kind of
get into it. Right.
How does active inference see these
these sort of time streams, like
are there little local times
with little thicknesses around them?
What is this?
So in this idea of minus pro emergence,
you have a doubly emergent time
that's emergent on two fronts.
So you have a local, singular,
condensed time
which is sort of the time
that we all experience
this very like, you know, I'm presenting
to your lovely community nine or 6 a.m.
This is like Shana's now, right?
But there's also like
you know, Alpha Centauri
now and then, Unicorn Constellation now.
Right.
So there's all these different nouns
and whose now is what?
So you have these like local,
singular time, and then you're going to
actually have this global.
What I'm going to try to push for
is a non locality in the diamonds.
So to rephrase the holographic principle
and kind of upgrading AIDS, which is
anti disorder space, which is the bulk
which has gravity in it.
I'm going to try to actually rebuild
that from the six functor formalism.
So that's what you see in this figure
with these sort of six columns
as the six operations from Peter Shull
says, a telco emoji at diamonds.
It's so beautiful.
So imagine building space from a functor
formalism, which is very, very specific.
And then
if you're going to get the
conformal field theory,
which has no gravity, I was thinking, OK,
so the gravity list should could be
in the finite condition of the diamond.
So you see I have a bunch of diamonds
kind of glued together.
And so maybe this gluing in the diamond
condition can kind of,
you know, replace the conformal
field theory.
So in this,
you can actually get a holography.
That's really interesting to think
what active inference thinks about
holography.
Like, what's the actual reflection?
What's the actual object?
So you can relate this to strong and weak
coupling.
You know, whichever theory is strong,
right?
Has a strong coupling,
which is like, you know, the tension
you know, in the interaction terms.
And so you can relate,
you know, whichever one
has maybe a weaker coupling,
you normally use
like a perturbation theory
the stronger coupling, you have to use
a non perturbation methods.
So it's very physics oriented.
And, you know, the beauty
and the duality is that
if one space is too hard,
you go to the other space.
So this is really fun.
And this is isn't the
I sort of have this grand opus paper,
the top 21, you're like
she refers to it all the time.
Yeah. OK, so the goal. Right.
So I said you're going to have
this pro emergent thing which is like
has multiple emergent times going on this
not just emergent time,
but I think they're all over the place.
So in that is what I'm going to call
stack time.
So Stack is going to be
this particular object
that takes values and categories,
not just so we're not looking at like
the set of continuous functions,
but maybe you're looking at the category
of continuous functions.
And every object in the category
is a continuous function.
So you're getting this sort of grand
unified view
of of objects,
which is really, really neat.
I say V because it's it's going to be
a stack with a V topology on it.
I think I spoke
last time that you can actually put
a topology on categories,
and that's what I'm really interested in.
So the ecology is Peter
Shull says topology that he's
using for the diamonds and it's, it's
a nice fine topology.
And I'll go into it in a little bit.
So the big questions that are driving
some kind of wild diagram
that I have here
in the middle of this con
diamond is like,
what is the mathematics of simultaneity?
So I'm really interested in what we mean
by simultaneity.
And we say
two events happen at the same time.
What time is that?
And is there a difference?
And what is the difference
between simultaneity and non locality?
Not locality.
You know,
you have spatial known locality,
maybe the view
from a pair of entangled photons.
And then what does temporal not locality
mean that time is actually everywhere,
that there is no difference in time
between events.
Right.
You have events
that are maybe spread out into space,
but maybe they happen at the same time.
So I'm really interested
and what kind of mathematics would be
able to hold something like that?
Right.
Maybe you have a bunch of multiplicities
going on, but they're all at once.
So, you know, I'm asking what is embodied
cognition in non locality?
How could you actually
reframe one of the fundamental tenants
of like active inference
based on like reframe it
a non locality, not a progression, but
what would actually happen all at once?
So this is where I think
the mathematics would actually help,
like infinity categories
in this double emergence
that I'm talking about.
So I talked about infinity categories
last time.
These are categories that have a lot
of a lot of rich structure in them.
And you're able to create more isms
between morph isms and between morph isms
all the way up to Infinity Morph isms,
which is really, really beautiful.
So maybe the claim, maybe it's
kind of a wild claim
is that embody cognition like is emergent
time.
Right.
So what am I going to, you know,
hopefully that's something that can
I can kind of show throughout these
slides, embody cognition like is
emergent time.
So again, the basis behind emergent
time is was it always here?
I don't
I don't know, was time always here?
Who knows?
And that's what I'm kind of after.
So in this diagram,
you see I have this spot of Q,
which is the added spectrum
I'm going to go into.
On the other side, you have Spark Up,
which is the attic spectrum of the attic,
the diamond interpretation
with the little diamond on top
You've got these two factorization
matches expose
from Fargo's work on his geometry ization
of the local England.
So heavy math in this,
which is really beautiful.
On the bottom. You've got this y diamond.
See, these are
this is called the diamond interpretation
of the dark fontane curve.
This is an attic curve that has an actual
for bonus action on it.
And so this curve is very important.
It's used in the landlords program,
which is the, you know,
the top a grand
unified theory of mathematics right now.
So then you have these Elon maps
that are mapping up
whatever openings
into what I call condensed diamond.
So the condensed category is Peter
Charles's construction about
category of condensed objects.
And I go into those.
It's a beautiful idea
about sheaves over points.
So anybody in the crowd here
knows what a sheaf is.
It's like a awesome topological way
of keeping track of local data,
local data, local data, local data,
like a little bag.
And so, like,
normally you have sheaves over
spaces, but here is an actual sheaf
over a singular point.
And so he's he and
Dustin Wilson have
been like putting together this really
awesome lecture notes on this topic.
So it's great. It's in its infancy
and I think it's great.
So that diamond is a conjecture of mine.
But you take the diamond
I talked about last time
and you can actually extend it
to the infinity category of diamond.
So I call that do
diamond lot of stuff in that diagram.
But this is what I think
is actually the esthetic
because you know what
if we could actually map this to like,
you know, a string
theoretic interpretation or something,
then you get the Grand Unified
Theory of math and physics.
OK, so
let me open that just a little bit.
So if you take let's see, be
the category of diamonds, let condensed C
be the category of condensed objects
and see objects are condensed diamonds.
All right. That's what's in there.
Let are be the reflective,
full subcategory of condensate.
This is a subcategory.
We're all objects
and are actually reflections
of objects in the bigger category.
So it's very neat.
You have diamonds
and they're reflections.
So objects in our reflections.
So if you take the diamond to be,
then if any one category of diamonds,
you can extend this to Candy Diamond.
It's a condensed diamond
and you get the sexual object.
So following precedent, from Fargo's
amazing work, the fiber product of this
diagram has claimed a modular space
and a diamond.
That's very hard.
All right. So that's that's hard.
So modular.
I ve stacked time.
So let's take this condensed diamond
and just up it just a little bit.
So I have this other conjecture right?
Let's take.
So the way that you get these diamonds,
I don't have to figure out.
I have a figure of a diamond very,
very soon.
The way you get the diamond
is by taking equivalence classes.
Certain protocol equivalence
classes of these
objects called perfected spaces,
which are like Perkovich Space.
It's kind of like cancer objects.
And so you through those together
and you get a diamond.
Well, why don't we glue diamonds together
and get something else?
So you can do that.
So if you can take diamond equivalence
relations of this
diamond curve, then you can get a stack
and the V topology.
And why don't we work
in the modular space of B stack?
So modulus space is this awesome
parameter space where each point
represents
an isomorphism class of objects.
So you're looking at so each point,
like in this little figure below
is an Isomorphism class.
And so the question is like, you know,
how do you move in a diagram like that?
Is it a chessboard? Is it.
Can I only move this way and this way
and this way?
So I'm really interested in
like what it means phenomena
logically to have something like this
and to start in the upper left,
like dot and jump to the
like the bottom right dot.
So how do you actually move
through this thing?
So I'm thinking that
every point of that modulo space
would actually be an incarnation
of the condensed new diamond diagram.
So that that huge factorization
with these maps
would actually be at each point.
And I think that's actually
really beautiful.
So that's the type of like grand
unified theory I'm kind of thinking of.
Yeah.
So these Elon maps play a dual role of
what's called topological localization.
Localization is a beautiful phenomena,
a beautiful way of actually
constructing equivalencies between
between objects.
And so topological localization passes
through this reflective subcategory.
So objects are being sort of stared
at by their reflections.
And it's a way of getting more
equivalencies and maps.
So I'll just leave it at that.
So this pro terminology,
this is a little mathy, but I thought,
you know, we're let's do it.
I'm not going to go super mathy,
but I wanted to give you enough terms
so, you know,
like what I'm talking about.
So for this pro
which I think is very cool,
the idea is that emergence is built
into the very space as a pro object
and not as additional counter terms.
I think that I can make the active
inference community does that as well.
You want everything
sort of built into the structure
as opposed to adding these counter terms.
There's a lot of beautiful like form
and path integral work
that has all of these
these additional counter
terms added to it.
And it's like, I wish it could just
be built into the actual space.
So you can actually do that
with this pro terminology Right.
So a pro object, all this is there's
a great reference called Inkjet Lab.
It has all these definitions.
So I'm pulling all these
and lots of great lecture
notes on any kind of pro object
So what does a pro object, a pro
object of a category C is a form
of cocoa, filtered limit of objects of C.
So basically, roughly
what we mean by this code filtered limit
is that for every two objects, C, one,
C, two, and C, you have a third object,
C three, and C,
that they both get mapped to it.
So it's sort of self-contained
You see, it's built into the structure.
You don't have to go off
and leave the category to find the limit.
So you have a functor
also.
So what you do,
you take us to be a closed, symmetric,
minor middle category closed.
I have the definition
for both of these symmetric modal means
that has a tensor product
and you take C and S in rich category,
which means that it takes values,
the whole set of C text values and s,
you have this enriched form Functor,
which is written like this, C
takes in two pairs going from the product
of C opposite with itself
or C opposite is the same category.
The arrows are just reversed to S
that sends a pair of objects
and C to this hum object,
which is a collection of Morph isms.
So look at that.
You're actually mapping
each pair of objects
to where it can go
right to all the possible paths.
And I think this is very nice.
So a closed category means for any pair
cc prime of objects.
The collection amorphous MS
is an actual object of c,
so everything is inside of itself.
And it's sort of
like a categorical closure property.
Right? Anyone familiar
with just the closure property of
that?
You learn it like abstract algebra.
So this is called the internal hum
object.
Right.
So five the pro functor.
So with the pro terminology,
you can actually have a pro functor
which generalizes the word term functor.
So let's C and D both be enriched over.
See the pro functor from Saturday's
An S Functor.
So that's enriched with deep tensor
C over S.
So again,
taking the pairs and mapping them over.
So you can also make this into,
like I told you, this modulo space right?
Right here with the points
where isomorphism classes
are r each point
and they can vary geometrically.
And I'll go into what that means.
And you can get stacks from that.
So I think I'll finish the pro and
then ask if there's any questions and.
Just to wrap up this, OK, before you,
let's get the super sticky stuff
out of the way.
All right.
So what's also beautiful
and all over the Leyland's
program is the idea of a finite group.
So you can see that
you can take this pro language,
this kind of multi gluing
and self-contained ness
and extend it to a finite group,
which is a top
a logical group
that's isomorphic to the inverse limit
of an inverse system of discrete
finite groups.
So this inverse limit over the discrete
finite groups is a finite groups
that they all have the discrete topology,
and you have a collection
of some amorphous
sums that satisfy nice relations
So my idea is like, OK, let's,
let's let's up the game even more.
There's a lot of work about spectra and
prime spectra, and this is also a graph
and where the spectrum of a ring,
I think I talked about it last time,
is a certain
the spectrum of varying refers is a space
where the actual points of the space
refer to prime ideals.
So again, you have this like point
referring to something higher
than a point.
OK, so you can extend that to what I call
a formal spectrum.
So then you have this great idea of like
including infinitesimals and things.
So it's not like you have a singular now,
but what if we had a singular now
with a little bit of infinitesimal
thickening on it, right?
Like every, every now
or every like local time of ours
had a little bit of thickening
and we could call that
an infinitesimal thickening.
And so he actually has the same idea
and he calls it formal spectra.
So we say the formal spectrum stuff
are of cumulative ring are in an ideal
that to be certain properties,
it's actually the inductive limit
of the prime spectrum.
So inductive limit meaning like this.
So the the pro refers
to a projective phenomena
on the end refers to an inductive.
So it's like a code limit.
So as far as the co
limit of spec are I n,
which is where R is complete
with the erratic
topology, there's various ways
of completing rings in the attic.
So we're expecting more isms
or these closed nail cogent emotions
spec our AI and immersed
with spec our AI and plus one.
So these are of fine schemes
and the column is taken in the category
of topological range spaces.
So what is a
what is a closed and l potent immersion?
So an L potent phenomena is some property
that you take an element,
raise it to a certain power
and eventually go to zero.
So it's a way of canceling out elements.
The Affine scheme is a ringed space.
It's a top, a logical space, and it has
a structure sheath, which is again
this kind of thickening thing.
So imagine a space
with a little bit of light skin on it.
And so I'm thinking that, OK, it's
not just a pro
emergence of point, it's
a pro emergence of these formal spectra
which are like times intervals
with little thick endings on them.
So no point in elephants and I say
elephant.
No, no golden elephants,
no button elements are
our infinitesimal neighborhoods.
And so a beautiful
way to complete again
to complete the ring
having convergence issues like settled
is to actually take at it completion.
So at it completion
is to actually have all the infinitesimal
neighborhoods at once.
And I think that's a grand goal.
And anybody after at a completion
to have all the thickening right
is what is probably
what we should be after.
Any questions on that so far?
Before I get to the fun,
just I. Yep.
OK. Thanks for this interesting intro.
I think one thing that's really going
to resonate with people
hopefully of all different backgrounds
is what you said about We want emergence
built into the base structure
of our model, not a counter term,
which isn't a term that's familiar to me,
but it's kind of like magic
shouldn't be added at the higher level.
We should have a model where at the base
level we have emergence.
And then you mentioned
the pairs of objects
and a few different
kind of pair operations like inverses.
And so I was just wondering
how should we think about these pairs
of objects, for example,
are they organisms in the niche
or the two organisms?
Because if so, then we can kind of think
every time you say pair,
we might be able to map it onto something
that we've talked about from the embodied
cognitive perspective.
Oh, I like that. Yeah, go ahead,
try that.
Try that.
You know what?
You could take the category sea
of organisms and then it can be
any two organisms in the actual category.
If you wanted the category to be,
you know, pairs of organisms
like organism Daniel,
the organism Shannon
or something different,
then you could actually
construct the category to be that.
That's the beauty of category theory.
You construct it to be whatever you want
because structurally the goal,
the goal is to get everything
built inside the actual space
and to have these consistency issues
that you're not like, Oh,
well, yeah, you know, so like
we come online
and then there's this counter term, oops.
So you actually have it more organism
is relating to or interacting
with like organism, right?
Or you can actually have a category
B, just the way that my organism
is identifying
and interpreting information
like whatever you want
those objects to be.
It's completely this.
Cool, thanks.
And I'll relay any questions
from live chat in another ten slides.
Yeah, all this cases so great. Yeah.
So we're all on the same page,
you know, built it,
build it into the structure, you know,
and if you want
the structure centered around, you know,
you can actually have this C three
being like the organism.
Daniel the organism.
Shana that everything maps back to me
because that's what we're doing right?
And everything comes back to me.
I'm trying to process. OK, cool.
All right. So
OK, this is a these,
these ideas might just all be wild, but
I'm glad you know, I'm here to help you.
All right, so now I don't know,
this is where my brain thinks.
OK, so we have the idea of an info
morph ism,
which is an actual pair of an adjoining
pair of functor sits on a choose space.
And my colleague, my great colleague
Chris Fields has done so much work
with that.
You know, Chris, the upstairs of that
Levon all the time,
they come up with this great stuff.
So an info Marxism is one pair,
one set of joint funders which
which satisfies some information.
My idea is to make a two
and info morph ism
from these six functor formulas.
So in these kind of wild equations
down here,
the two tails is, is a structural
property, an internal home
and an actual tensor product
how you actually combine things.
But the four in the middle
represent two pairs of joint functor.
So one set of two pairs inform our prism.
I just want to actually construct
a two and four morph ism,
which would actually be a morph
ism between morph ism.
So that's a categorical thing
at this point.
We're working on the semantics of what
that actually means right now.
And so bear with us.
That should be out very, very soon.
So what is this?
The idea is the incarnation of global
time emerges from dimension locality.
So what I just tried to say
local time emerges
from these singular condensed sets.
The two and four morph
ism is going to connect the global time
with the local time.
That's the whole point, right?
That's how your organism evolves right?
That's how you deduce
is to connect your local time
with what's actually happening
globally, right?
These cannot be singular.
They have to intersect at some point.
So if this to and fro more present
can actually do that, then
you can actually get this temporal
simultaneity non locality.
I'm still not convinced
that there is a difference
between simultaneity and non locality.
I would love it for anyone in your,
you know,
if anyone's like interested in that.
That's, that's really that's tricky
because maybe,
maybe the instance of simultaneity
is a slice of the non locality
or maybe we were actually in tune enough
with what's happening like
like embodied cognition wise or whatever
that we were actually able
to access for just a second.
Maybe the true non
locality of everything.
That is the normal reality
of information,
whatever you want to call it. What is the
difference? I don't really know.
People normally refer to like
special relativity and reference frames
and I have a couple of questions about
what reference frames are so any time.
You know I, I think I'm going to tackle
a new subject, I invent a new dictionary.
I'm like,
OK, let's start with a dictionary
to actually translate
what I'm talking about.
OK, so the notion of a site in category
theory is where I can put it topology.
So I'm thinking
if I'm, you know, for instance,
looking at the site of an organism,
you know, investigating its environment,
something like this, the site of Shana,
that could and that's a categorical,
categorical way of actually
referring to the localization phenomena
in the collapse.
Right.
So quantum
mechanics is saying you go from,
you know, the collapse of the way
function is great.
I go from a simultaneous like
superposition state to like a localized.
Now, of course, there's,
you know, controversy about the collapse
and things like that.
That's
why I'm using the word localization.
You localize in the now
so coupling perturbation, right?
So again,
strong coupling, you have to use these,
these
non preservative methods we coupling,
you can use perturbation
there's a I think there's a link
between perturbation and this.
It's stuff that I've been looking at.
So there's a way called called tilting
to go from characteristic zero
if people are familiar with that
to characteristic P, you can also add
these beautiful objects called
P divisible formal group laws which are
once again I would say ways of connecting
like groups.
The kernels of these actual maps
are repeated the in torsion.
So the torsion element
actually annihilates any other element.
So an element is torsion if it actually
is annihilated by another element.
So you continue to have these P
to the N sort of phenomena
that are canceling terms.
So the whole idea is
that you can get this cancelation
and sort of a sequence phenomena
also in perfect spaces.
So there's also torsion in these objects
called shimmer varieties,
which we'll talk about later.
That's in the language is conjecture,
strong coupling, maybe it's strong,
you know, maybe in the diamond
we could say strong
coupling is in the diamond side
of the holography.
Because there's many incarnations
of these covers.
False.
And I'll go into this little bit later
just trying to put the ideas up
front week coupling, right?
So maybe you can do perturbation
phenomena in the condensed setting
in the interior, you know, so maybe
that's in the singular perfect wait time.
It's weak because it's condensed.
Maybe it's easier to work with protocol
covers than in the condensed setting.
So it make you work in the conformal
field theory, which is the diamonds.
So the whole relation
to the diamond holography is that
if you have these six operating zones
right in the bulk,
then you're going to have to go
from the bulk to the conformal field.
So maybe the inside is
the six operations, you know,
whichever one you
want to call strong and weak coupling.
So what do I what do I need to finish?
Well, you need to like I need to actually
take the six operations
and put them in the condensed setting
and then link the diamond
for finite conditions with non locality.
So you get what's called diamond descent.
Descent is
another way, like Daniel was saying,
about keeping the system contained.
The center is a way of actually
making sure that the covering spaces
can can reconstruct the lower space.
So my local space is actually constructed
from my globe,
my global space, and vice versa.
This is another way
of keeping the structure
built inside the actual space.
OK, and we'll talk about Diamond
Localization, which is going to be a way
to make relations
between the various diamonds.
All right.
So, well, let's try to link this. Right?
So we're call and info morphs some.
It's an add joint pair structure
preserving maps for a choose space.
The beauty about two spaces that's
got a very, very nice construction.
Categorically the true construction
build builds what's called
a star autonomous category
this is a mineral category.
It has a tensor product in then
to help you move
objects around
where all objects have duals.
Right.
So I thought this might be interesting
for my body cognition
because maybe you're looking around
at your reflection
and learning off
of your reflection. Right?
And where are these reflections?
Everywhere.
So if all objects have doors, that's
a very strong property for a category,
which is where there's a lot of type
theory and stuff that works in the space.
So you also have a category
five for business algebra.
This is an associative algebra
with a linear form on it.
I told you for business
was even in the language, right?
So forgiveness is powerful in body
cognition, everything is related, right?
So you want everything to be related.
So what if what if everything was a star
autonomous category?
So I think the true construction
is actually very pertinent here.
So if the hidden states,
what if those are like a pro finite
condition or a pro object
that maybe just only become
visible upon a certain pullback?
So in the diamond construction
that I gave you,
it said those those geometric points
were mathematical impurities.
Yeah.
That they were not invisible unless
you pulled them back over these covers.
There's once again a lot of work
about neurology, acting topological,
meaning that your proprioception
is gotten by these topological covers
where portions of the mind
or the brain are actually
working together.
And we're where we're portioned
sort of intersect and overlap.
That's that's a covering phenomena
and that's how you actually deduce
and things like this.
So shared action.
OK, OK, so if we were for after shared
action, you know what?
If we start looking at relations
between relations,
that's where the shared action is.
We want to think collectively. Yeah.
In the face of uncertainty,
if we start thinking in the framework
of two morph ism,
then you're already in the global space.
And I think there's nothing more shared
than working in the relation
of the relation space.
Instead of being so siloed,
you can be siloed
in your own localization,
but that's not going to help
for shared action to actually.
So if everyone can get a hold
of everyone else to morph isms, you know,
what does that mean?
And that means they're actually
all intersecting and interacting.
You can take that and go to in awareness,
which is what my awesome colleague
Robert Putnam
and I've been working on as well
that, you know, I'm
not sure I think I said that last time,
that I do not believe that
there's only one channel here. Right.
I feel like through shared action
you could access
more of these sort of consciousness
channels.
And so that in awareness
is actually a categorical phenomenon
that I can show here.
So I think I showed this last time,
but I'll just show it again.
So on the left,
you have a basic depiction of a category.
This one right here,
my little mouse is not working.
All right. So the one on the left,
top row left.
So you have
to two objects here and B F1
and you want to work Ism's.
Right?
You have two objects, Sandy, F
two and G2 or those are Morph isms.
We'll call them one Morph isms.
Let's go to the category in the middle.
So category middle is a two category.
Oh, and I'm sorry, the category on
the left is a one category.
So if you go to a two category
in the middle,
you have the same objects, ABCD
and the same 11 more pheasants.
But look at these wild maps on the side.
So your mapping look,
look what we're mapping on the left.
You're mapping
the morph ism f one to G to buy that map.
See and then you're also by gamma,
you're mapping a
G G one to F two.
So this is awesome.
So look what we're doing there.
Now you're mapping the Morph isms
between the Morph isms
and this is where I think shared
action lives.
You can go even wilder
because you know, it's me.
So the third, the third cat,
you can have a three category,
which is the top right piece.
And look at that.
A three category consists of objects.
One morph isms between the objects
to morph, isms
between the one morph isms.
And then look at the three morph ism
you have going on the big double bar,
triple bar, horizontal bar
that's connecting fee and gamma.
They're rising.
So you see you can just keep going.
And why not? That's for a collection.
Yeah, go ahead.
I just wanted to give one little thought
on this.
It's almost like,
yes, let's say ABCD people and then yes,
the two mapping
is kind of like best friends or marriage.
It's like two people who are married.
There's some parallelism between couples
of married people and then the three is
like the mapping between marriage
and being a best friends.
And so it's like saying the relationship
between person A and B in the marriage
is like the relationship between A
and B in the best friend relationship.
So it's like we can put the relationship
and almost objectify it,
but not in a demeaning way,
just in a containing formal way,
and then use that to build
higher order relationships.
So this is like very interesting.
Look at that. Yeah, you say it.
I should just give you
my slides and you present.
It's a co it's a co presentation
and we as an as a dyad are interacting
with the material
you've prepared as well as any questions
that anyone else brings out.
And so does everyone see.
So like collectively.
Oh, that makes me excited.
So collectively, like even
this interaction
is like a three morph ism right now.
And so that's actually really cool.
And you see
I like it. Yeah.
The with like marriage maybe, you know,
maybe if you stayed in the one category,
you would have just been friends
and you would have never actually tried
the other relationship
or the other relationship.
Or you can go like, you know, twin planes
and all this kind of stuff.
And so it's actually really exciting.
And so you can see just like Daniel
saying that's shared action
and let's like
let's take shared action to infinity
and then what
a beautiful place this would be.
You know, you kind of have like,
you know, the people like me that are,
you know, related to animals, too.
So it'd be like, oh, OK.
So then you have the Morpheus in between
like the fade away with the animals
talking to like the humans and then
like oceans and things like that.
And then you might start
relating on the higher
like higher connection level, right?
Not hierarchical,
but like a higher connection level.
And so you can see that Robert
and I, we're trying to think, OK,
let's, let's get weird and like take,
you know, the one level of awareness
which is like, you know, Daniel
and I co presenting here because he's
says my slides better than me.
So that's the co presentation right?
Is maybe like a one awareness.
OK, and then two awareness.
Let's, let's just bump
this up a little bit
would be that,
you know, he and I are presenting here
and then simultaneously like
we're both Cambridge apostles.
What.
Yes, that's the level
that I'm willing to go. Right.
Because if time is not local,
which I sort of think it is
why can't we map to it
using these Morph isms?
Right.
Of course we'd have to do
some kind of partition in the brain
or whatever, but we'll get to that later.
But that's what
we're saying about this nested hierarchy.
So use the same everything that Daniel
saying about the categories, right?
One, Category two, category
three category and bump it to
like awareness,
meaning actual interaction.
Like let's take in body cognition
and bump it like what would a
two embodied cognition be?
A three embodied?
And let's keep going up
because that would require higher,
higher levels of this awareness.
The statue thing.
And again,
the bit about this is that, look,
we didn't add some counter term, right?
We didn't just add, you know,
the whole thing is magic.
Of course, and, you know, I love magic,
but we didn't just add it out of nowhere.
This was like built into the
actual structure, which I think is cool.
So again, most people
maybe intimidated by Category
three or whatever at the first,
but it's like I think there's a payoff.
It's like let's
let's put a little bit of work
into that structure
and then you can make this esthetic.
And it actually I think it helps,
you know,
so just an overview real quick,
I'm going to try to talk about this,
you know,
this emergent time
a little better and a concomitant theory
of condensed types, which are supposedly
this supposed to be immediate
from the recently introduced
diamond holographic principle.
You've seen me already
kind of introduce that.
So if you're connecting this
beautiful mathematical grand unified
theory of geometry as local language
in the stack language with emergent time,
that would be a new incarnation
of a new reciprocity law.
You see, I'm using the word incarnation
to refer to diamonds and reflections.
Yeah.
And also choose faces.
And for Morpheus, I'm star autonomous.
All of this star
autonomous objects, having doors,
reflections, reflective subcategories,
pro finite condition.
It's all about the mirror phenomena,
which is in embodied cognition, I think.
Of course, there's problems everywhere,
which is why I'm excited about this.
Right? Problems everywhere.
You know, you can talk about
a theory of emergent time.
How do you measure that?
How do you actually measure time
without constructing it?
And that that is like, that's huge.
That'll stump me.
You know, I talk fast. I'm like,
wait, wait.
So how do you how do you measure
a double emergent something?
It's crazy as I'm talking about,
how do you measure a pro emergence?
How do you measure like, you know,
if you want to do this categorical
construction, like we're doing
a two emergence, a three emergence,
I don't know.
And that's what I hope, too.
So we can all work together,
figure this out.
How do you actually measure emergence?
It's like, do you collapse the margins?
Are you too late?
If you measure it too early, is it
a partial emergence and you've missed it?
If we sneeze do we miss it? Is it fast?
You know, so our model gains levels
of non locality, levels of non locality.
And I'm just saying like, you know, there
exists a spatial among locality no.
If you can put them together
in that formal spectra,
what if you had levels of non
locality everywhere?
And that's sort of what I'm into.
So I call it like a stacking on locality
and stack ification.
I think stack ification is a word like
spaghetti ification and it does exist.
I may have misspelled it. Sorry.
All right.
So you can do local this.
You know,
I'm interested one of your awesome
members of the community was asking me
about like, what are you talking about?
This local global
meaning like the local singular
now is like where I'm existing now.
And then of course, you know,
you have your unicorns Constellation Time
on this Eros and all this other stuff.
So that's when there's a play here
between taking in information
and then like existing and stuff.
So you can do this by this time
and again,
I told you this gluing
and that's gonna be an infinite
one version of spatial V descent,
which is up here.
So this is work diamond localization.
So what's already neat is that once again
I talked about the emergence
is built into the structure,
this localization, those L maps
in the reflective subcategory,
it's already a descent condition.
Whoa, so let's use these beautiful
theorems, right?
And actually use them for phenomenology,
for phenomenology.
And so that's already a descent
condition.
So we're on our way you know,
so the goal is to actually link
like strong and weak coupling.
How do you actually construct
this diamond non locality
for a temporal multiplicity?
I think that's really in tune
with embodied cognition is to have
a multiplicities
time, meaning like there is not just one,
but it's what
how could you actually model time acting
globally non locally
but also in a multiple way
and that's super French
continental philosophy at that point.
And you know, that's like my upbringing
so I'm really interested
in this phenomenon multiplicity
because at least
it lets the individual be
and it makes like when a body cognition
is like what I feel it is.
So I'll have to build
this diamond descent.
And then again these V stacks are going
to have to satisfy this living condition.
That's fine.
Our model is a double emergence,
but it's finite.
Many copies of emergence.
That's what strange.
I told you last time a finite set
was a totally disconnected
compact has high storage space.
So that's, that's
what like what is that, you know,
not sort of a totally disconnected
compact space not or so,
but so the pro finite is very strange.
It's like, what is that?
If you have pro final and many copies
of something, what is that actual space?
So if you have this double emergence
and it's very kind of fractal
like I'm really interested in that.
So again, maybe the strong coupling
has to do with irreversibility
and reconstruct ability.
I'm very, very interested.
And what we mean by, you know,
something is irreversible, right?
I think we need to go into that
just little bit more.
And is there a play between
irreversibility and reconstruct ability?
Right.
The descent condition
as you can reconstruct
this higher space in this level space,
what does it mean
that if you like, fail to reconstruct?
So we say it's a diamond X, like
reconstruct a ball up to irreversibility.
You've seen that up to condition
in mathematics, which is like a is
sort of equal to be up to some condition,
meaning can considering that condition.
So the hope is that. Yes.
So if I can get this play between
reconstruct ability and irreversibility,
maybe that'll make more sense
mathematically
for what it means to be irreversible.
So coupling the strings of the coupling
would be in the levels of the finiteness
and the non locality. How many levels
do you actually have there?
What's the string?
So coupling by perturbation,
I already said that's perfect.
Do it in tilting.
So big questions.
What would actually non locality
be an act of reference?
I mean, I'll leave these rhetorically
because I want to get to this.
That pretty image Danielle, before
we wait for possible, the next question.
So I think it's like coming up.
Yes, right.
OK, so what is known locality
and active inference?
What is holography
and active inference right?
Which is this very awesome
dimensional phenomena
where there's a strong interaction
and you know say dimension in
and then maybe there's
like a weaker interaction and in -1,
what does that mean?
And that if one space is too difficult,
you go to the other space,
what does that actually mean?
And they're actually related,
sort of like a hologram.
So hologram
is this 2D kind of scrambled image
that maybe you bounce light on
and you get this 3D phenomena.
So in one sense, the 3D is redundant.
Because you already had it in 2D.
So what is the notion of redundancy
and active inference?
That's what I'm interested in.
So what is a diamond equivalent of pro
finite and active
where's the fractal ness
that's sort of happening?
Right, the fractal multiplicity, what is
object persistence and active inference?
That's tricky, right?
So you know, when we you know,
we say, you know, the observer measures
the electron and things like this,
you know, the pair of entangled photons,
you know, X
non-local or something, like this,
what does that actually mean?
Why is it the same photon?
And so Chris Fields and I
are trying to work on this awesome
idea of object persistence
and what that actually is right?
I mean, you saw me a couple of weeks
ago, right?
But is it the same shannah?
How does that work?
How does objects persistence work
when you're going through
like a multiple time, you know,
what is emergent
time and active inference?
Where is it more likely where in embodied
like cognition is emergence?
So what is pro emergence there?
So I want you to think about these
as we're kind of going through
what is a singularity, right?
And act of inference like
a singular event, what is coupling right?
What is the actual coupling?
What is the strength
of an interaction mean?
So if you want to play hard for shared
action amid global uncertainty,
maybe we should work in discrete time
operating grand unified theories,
master this local global localization
by these higher order awarenesses.
Machine learning, right?
Operating grand unified theories.
Let's go higher, right?
Let's not work in networks anymore.
Let's work in three more isms medical.
OK, let's model the brain as a hologram.
Maybe these thoughts of these certain
chromatic towers I talked about the the
chromatic commentary theory last time.
It has this beautiful notion
of equating spectra.
You have this notion of this theorem
called Traumatic Convergence Theorem.
That says that you can reconstruct,
you can reconstruct a certain object
from its towers of spectra.
So you have a boost
field localization, which
which is sort of like the idea of my
the topological localization
I referred to,
which is a way of sort of connecting
spaces.
And again, if if you know,
you know, if in certain neurological
maybe degeneration, maybe
the actual morph isms are cut, you know,
you can think about things like that.
You're no longer able to recall because
maybe all the maps are gone, right?
So maybe that you could more aptly model
things like anterograde, amnesia,
neurodegeneration, so medical level
and Levin and Fields have this awesome
kind of new work out about entanglement
across star cells.
What is holography and daughter cells?
At least it's at least
we can measure entanglement
in something besides photons, you know,
so you need this
particularity is temporal non locality.
Is it like instantiation
without reciprocity?
It's Advent, right?
This is me going like wild here.
So Advent means that you've arrived,
but you've been in body cognition,
the environment has arrived.
I've arrives double play, right?
So is it an instantaneous ness
without a sort of two way interaction?
What does that actually mean?
What is temporal non locality mean?
I don't really know.
Can we actually construct, for instance,
a finite version of that, which is again,
this kind of super disconnected
fractal space is temporal
non locality, daily theism time.
Everyone knows I'm superfan of dilithium.
This is a construction of logic
where you can have both A
and not A at the same time.
Normally you cannot, right?
You have a, you know, a, A or B either,
you know, not A, therefore B
why can't A
and not obtain at the same time
so you get this beautiful construction
called dialectic, is it?
We may start messing around enough
so it there's a diamond construction
of temporal known locality fail time is
it fails all pro incarnations of duration
so you get a lot of interesting
heavy questions with this.
If so, what are the actual conditions
for object persistence in a non locality
that is pro finite.
How do you actually do that right
how does something persist
in those conditions?
How does persistence work in a singular
case such as anterograde amnesia?
You know,
I spoke of a Clive Waring last time
you know, was a beautiful pianist.
He's still living, which is great,
but he got an interim grade amnesia
and has no more personal memory
but has a motor memory
and so there's, you know,
some some difficulties there.
But it's very interesting
how the memory levels work.
So the question is not really profound.
So at least try to hold on to it,
you know, with the smallest assessment.
Maybe this has to do with thoughts
and memory recollection.
We can go into that.
But first, a dream. OK.
Can I just make a few active inference?
Yes. There.
OK, so I'm recalling my thoughts here
by looking at the
paper, which I took notes on.
First,
you mentioned the dynamic persistence
and a multi skill persistence, and
that reminded me of the ship of Theseus,
which is like if you replace all the
planks of the ship, is it the same ship?
So it's a philosophy styled question.
And then we're approaching it
in a formal way
and then it comes very close
to active inference.
When you had the slide
a needed particular charity,
that reminded me of
Karl Christian's recent paper,
which was called a free energy principle
for a particular physics
and particular is a pun
because it means specific,
but also it means particle.
And so when we say a particle or a point,
it's like that is the unit of analysis
that we can pick up, we can make edges
between points and we can engage
in a higher level of network mapping.
So when we're thinking about particles
here,
and this way that particles
can be related in nested
models
or nested categories, I'm
not sure what technical what would be
we're kind of talking about a particular
approach.
Oh, I love this.
Yeah.
Just trying to give a little,
little active inference,
you know, throw out some red.
No, please.
Yeah.
Every ten slides, every fight stopped me.
So yes, I think, wow, how neat.
You see, that's like an incarnation.
It's like this
this this is, this is exciting.
Yeah. What a play.
That's perfect. I'm curious.
See what you think
about the next couple of slides.
OK, I say.
But first, right.
So you have all this mathy stuff.
We're gonna do this.
We're going to this you know, like,
you know, said recurring first and stuff,
pulling at everybody step a thesis,
but first a dream because
I want to get like a little pretty.
So we are interested
in the relation between diamond descent,
the stop mechanism.
So I know Fields and Levin and everyone
has been like baffled by that
at the stop mechanism that doesn't work
in something like cancer cells.
Yeah. When do things stop?
I'm actually very curious about that
and the storage and reflection
and recollection of profanely
many copies of information
and the form of mathematically impure
or geometric
points. Right. If you're modeling
neurons as
diamonds, what is whoa, OK,
you have covers of diamonds.
Like I said, you know,
if the proprioception is topological
and in the covers, then
maybe you could actually model neurons
as these diamond phenomenon
so someone like Clive Waring
has all the diamonds, but
the covers are cut, so it's almost like
you cannot access that.
Right.
Very interesting
when the actual balloons are cut,
you cannot get the balloon anymore
if they're attached to you.
So we posited a model of the brain
that's actually allowing for various
mathematical partitions in the brain
in the form of providing them
many copies of the diamond, right?
So there is a geometric points
which are morph isms of schemes.
Like I said, then maybe Anterograde
amnesia would resemble some kind of
sustained truncation of diamond descent.
Why are those maps continually
continuously cut?
Which is why I'm very interested
in this object.
Persistence so considering
temporal locality, can we model thoughts
as pro finite reflections of pro
atl, topological covers
oriented and non locality? Right.
Someone from your from your community
also has asked me up thoughts
and I was like,
that's such a great question.
What?
You know, clearly there's something like
there's an M field going on,
but it's something more than that.
And then the brain seems to operate
like a hologram as well.
So what is that? Right?
Are these actual the finite reflections?
You know,
like if you cannot organize
your thoughts, are things bouncing
all over the place?
You know, I was a lot of
people are internal are the is the
the diamond super
internally reflected at that point.
So this may help
I said you know to model the state
of being fully conscious
right during dreamless sleep.
No one has that
fully
conscious during the dreamless sleep.
What would that actually be
which perhaps takes the form
of sleeping in a diamond hourglass.
So, you know,
I write like kind of fantastical
mathematical fiction books and
this is my second one that I'm working on
about, you know,
sleeping in a diamond hourglass.
What does that actually mean?
So you're working in Diamond Time
at that point?
What does that mean?
Pro finite in many reflections of time,
which probably takes some kind of image
like this, right?
So I always have unicorns over
because I'm like, Oh, it's magic, right?
And what does that actually mean
to sleep inside of anything?
Hourglass, I'm very, very curious
because, you know, when we go to sleep
and nothing is really asleep,
your system is still functioning.
Right? But where do you go?
And I'm not sure what you know,
I'm going to put that out there
to your community.
What is that? Right.
Why can you not be fully conscious
during dreamless sleep?
Not the little brief, periodic
right of of dream sleep that you get,
but where is that?
So it'd be something
like sleeping in an hourglass,
which is actually very strange.
And it's like, Oh, God,
what if somebody takes the hourglass
and turns it upside down and shakes it,
you know?
But this would almost be an hourglass
without cardinality.
So there is no up or down here, you know?
And so section that book is coming out,
which is cool, but it's all it's
nested in in the finite condition.
If you're going to say
object persistence, that happens
when you sleep as well.
So to get to some of the math stuff,
there's some main conjectures.
I'll talk about the theory of diamonds
let's let's actually
look at that diamond shape again
and let's get into the diamond
holographic principle of the Forward
Fontaine Curve,
why we're using its helical homology.
And let's go to emergent time, you know,
or as far as many of these as we can.
So I may start skipping around Daniel
in the interest of time, you know,
so that we can get to the good stuff.
So I introduced
this kind of wild can conjecture
about this eponymous K theory of diamonds
in this localization sequence,
which is a co fiber sequence
and a modification of something
called continuous K theory.
So again, I told you earlier that maybe
continuous K theory is the way to go
if we're going to be modeling
emergent time
because you want to kind of stick
together
small pockets of, of, of local emergence.
So this this number two localization
sequence is a CO fiber sequence.
And you've got the K theory acting on D
little sub diamond and then K F.M.
off of the Diamond four Fontane curve
mapping to the f k theory of the non
diamond fork fontane curve
with a modification of this f continuous
working in the category of sheaves and
this is actually this third
left hand side is actually going
to be corresponded to the actual
that that'll make it to
the end is an actual continuous
K three spectrum of D diamonds.
So again, it's a way of actually
gluing together and looking at the
isomorphism classes
of what's happening in these diamonds.
So my idea is this
you have these pro finite mini copies
that of,
of the actual geometric impurities.
So you already have those and we actually
want to figure out what's happening
between those.
So what's a two morph schism
between the pro finite copies?
That's what my interpretation of the K
theory is going to be.
So you have this level,
let's go to a higher level.
K theory is actually looking at
what makes things like unified
at that higher level. So it's cool.
So the upper diamond is a stable
do allies will presentable
infinity one category of diamonds
D sub diamonds actually the complex of
V stacks of look will be spatial diamonds
where complex is a
sort of like a collection
and then you have the actual relative
fork fontane curve in the diamond.
So don't talk about that too too much.
Let's get to the actual diamond
holography principle.
But the diamond holographic
principle should fall out
and be immediate
from this localization sequence.
So once again, our diamond holographic
principle is going
to use these two joint pairs for these
you have a direct image,
an inverse image, functor,
and then an exceptional
and an inverse
exceptional functor, which is this
F lower sreak and F upper streak.
That's the kind of cool way of saying
exclamation point.
What's the main point is that again,
we want to take these double
joint pairs and make a two and four morph
as a matter of them.
So these are from shows six
operations, eight technology of diamonds.
We actually want to condense a find this.
So how do you rephrase all this
in terms of a sheaf of sets
like on a certain site
and then go into what that means
and then sort of, you know, how to
how do we think about holograph V
in terms of a mathematically
mathematical and purely geometric point,
the Spar CD, that's the static spectrum
of this closed algebraic curve
mapping to the actual diamond.
So again, try to think of a you know,
when we think about reflections,
we're trying to mathematically interpret
that.
So let's actually discuss immersion
time from that condensed setting.
An investigator condensed version
of the actual continuous K theory for pro
emergence, right?
That's wild.
So the continuous case
theory
or instances of marketing a.k.a theory
and then actually try to put the pro
object together as a pro emergence.
OK, so here's this image.
I think I showed it last time.
So the one of the main goals
is to actually have an infinity
one category ification of geometric
Englands England's England sorghum.
It's so beautiful.
What is it trying to do?
It's, it's a mathematical interpretation
of shared action.
You are working across very difficult,
disparate fields
with lots of uncertainty.
And so you have these beautiful phenomena
for England's reciprocity, Lenglen
to reality, where actually, you know,
you're creating a certain situation
in which certain
representations of objects
are actually automatic forms.
And so different incarnations
are being shown to be the same thing,
which is like a version
of the same thing, which is cool.
So in this model that I have here,
so the diamonds in the middle
and again, you have the famous case
theory of the actual diamond curve.
And at the bottom, you know, I said, oh,
this structure is, you know,
possibly an infinity one to a point,
which goes back to Daniel's
point
about bringing all the structure in.
So and it's only one
turquoise and failing category,
it satisfies a decent condition.
It's locally Cartesian clothes.
So everything maps to each other.
It's got a Kappa filter on it.
So everything is nice and contained,
which is really nice.
All right.
And so you can also these lines
can also be interpreted in terms of
I have a little note there
about a Lubin Tate formal sheath module.
This is a law to link once again, one of
these higher grade unified theories.
You can actually maybe link
the geometry zation of local languages
with FMF K through it.
So I'm just getting some super
mathy things that some people want.
It's mathy things, right?
So that's bunch things work,
which is really pretty.
So let me actually formally
define Diamond.
I don't think I did last time.
Yeah.
And then we get to the actual holography
part.
OK, so let perf d be
the category of perfected spaces.
So again, these are annex spaces.
They look like Huber spaces and they are
fractal and strange,
kind of like Perkovic spaces.
So let perf be that category
and perf be the subcategory
perfecto and spaces of characteristic p
so no longer zero p so a diamond is a pro
hotel sheet that's a sheave.
And the proton topology,
as I told you, is a very fine topology,
which can be written as a quotient
x, not r.
So it's of a
you take the perfect workspace
and you model out and you glue
these proto equivalence relations.
You get a diamond
what a beautiful way of doing that.
So we say, let's see main
algebraically closed F and right field,
it's a certain construction
and you percents
and then we say a geometric point
so this is the thing that I think
would be beautiful to actually the thing
this is the actual object
that could actually model neurons
very nicely geometric point
which is the attic spectrum of that C
mapping to the diamond is made visible
by pulling it back
through a protocol cover
xD resulting in profanely
many copies of spots.
So this is again huge relation
with like proprioception
by topology, right?
How do you actually visualize,
how do you interpret things like this?
So Diamond is an actual algebraic space
for that v topology.
And the Etiology typology everyone wants
to know is the sexual cover f i x my x
that consists of any maps excited x
such that for any quasi compact,
open subset,
you and x your final indices i
so that these these open subsets jointly
cover you so x there is an actual
v stack.
OK, so here's a diamond again, right?
So we can think
what are these actual geometric points
in terms of like embodied
cognition, in terms of, you know,
shared action,
whatever you want to think.
If, if I, you know, if I'm a diamond,
Daniel's not.
How do you actually relate those
to diamonds by these like big maps?
And so you can see that right here
you have this diamond.
So the actual footnote is calling it
what it is.
So you take the addicts, right,
which is the field optics, kewpie.
We can if we want to find the diamond
spectrum of that, which is that body.
So the diamond spectrum
that's akin to the actual prime spectrum,
the addict spectrum. I showed you.
So you can actually only ever
get the addict spectrum
a piece like Automata, which is a six
atomic field of the particles.
You don't actually get all the particles.
So this model out by the CB Cross,
which is a Galois action,
it's underlined because it's pro finite.
So how interesting
that you never actually get
you want the left hand side spotted cup,
but you only get pro
at the many copies of the six atomic.
So you never actually get
what you're after and this is actually
has a lot of phenomenology behind it
because like again, Robert and I really
and Chris and I are really fascinated
by the phenomenology of
what is so if we actually have, you know,
if you want to think interface
or if you want to think whatever it is
in our organism,
are we actually ever truly
interacting with the thing
or just our representation of the thing?
You know, you've got me at the level
going, well, you know,
if interaction is just me interacting
with a reflection of my environment,
if it's actually me interacting
with hidden states
that were probably my
reflections the whole time,
what is it?
Are we just sitting around with a finite
many copies of the thing?
We never actually get the thing.
Any questions for four?
I feel like it's a lot of math
yeah. There's pretty pictures.
Yeah. There's a question in the chat.
Oh, wonderful.
Yet KB writes, According to this
fascinating framework
and from an awareness perspective,
is the dark room problem
still considered as a problem?
Grateful for any elaboration on that.
And thanks to the speaker
so the dark room problem being the
philosophical thought experiment where
what does an agent in a dark room do
and in the free energy world?
Some people initially, several years ago
brought that up
as something like a critique.
They'd say, Well, aren't
you very precisely sure
that you're in a dark room?
So if active inference
is about reducing uncertainty,
then isn't that the perfect state?
But of course, the pragmatic answer
is that while you're in that dark
room, your uncertainty about the world
is increasing.
So I'm wondering if that maps on
to a multilevel uncertainty concept,
because it's almost like
you're getting precise
at the visual level
that you're in a dark room,
but you're getting increasingly imprecise
at not just a different lateral level,
like you're getting imprecise on smell
while you're getting precise on vision,
but actually at a higher level,
you're getting imprecise on visually
what's outside.
Oh, wow.
Well, yeah, keep going.
What do you think?
What a beautiful question.
Thank you so much.
Oh, yes.
More questions and less me talking.
Yeah.
I'm just I'm thinking of it as there's
three roads meeting in some ways here.
There's philosophy.
You know, we've brought up the dark room,
the ship of Theseus.
Then there's
a lot of the formal mathematics,
which certainly I'm scribbling down,
but are just beginning to learn.
And then there's the active
inference community who might be familiar
with this idea of multi-level
uncertainty. But.
Not have connected it
to, for example, philosophy or math.
So we've got people coming
and going on all those roads.
No, this is beautiful.
So it's like, yeah, yeah.
OK, so let's not take one
single dark room.
Let's expand it.
If every organism had their own
dark room.
Yeah, let's like, let's take that
question, accelerate it a little bit.
What a dark room.
Survive and a two info morph ism.
Right. Let's go a little.
Let's let's say you know, on
an information perspective, is it dark?
Probably not.
It's just on the organism perspective,
right?
So that's actually the dark
room is a very beautiful
I think, instantiation of what
I'm actually saying here with the demon.
So in the dark room
you may just have profaned like
many copies of the dark, but as Daniel
saying, like all your other senses
are being very, like, perfect weighted.
I'm just fine,
you know, other senses are being
more fine
tuned at the expense of something else.
So my question is this.
It's like,
why don't why can't we increase
the sort of bandwidth
to be able to be precise everywhere?
Like, why is it dark to the extent
of something else?
Right.
And how do we actually do that?
That's that's very interesting.
I think I think dark
room is still a problem.
Is anybody solve that?
It's still a problem, right?
I guess a problem for philosopher,
but not a problem for the human
in the dark room.
And let me ask 11 question
on the operations on diamonds.
Yes. People might be familiar
with the operations on numbers
like addition,
subtraction, multiplying, dividing
so is it fair to say that the operations
that you're going to be describing
there, like ways to work with diamonds,
just like plus and minus are ways to work
with numbers?
Oh, that's OK.
It's a very good, very good question.
So, you know,
we can answer that very abstractly
that there really is no intrinsic
definition of a number.
You can say the number five,
but what is it, five times one, you know,
six, six -1.
You have so many ways of going
going at it that a number is actually
just an equivalence class, right?
So if a number is just an equivalence
class, then
then you can think of the same thing
as a diamond.
Diamond still equivalence class, right?
A certain equivalence class between
but you're in a different
a different structure.
So sheaves you sheaves
don't really add like one plus one.
So there's a little more than you can.
Is there an algebra sheaves?
Oh, absolutely.
And the beauty is that sort of sheaves
are this like way of keeping
track of local data, like a little bag
that's associated to every space.
There are ways of gluing those together.
You don't really add them,
but you can glue them
and start gluing them and start
gluing them and start gluing them.
So in a sense, they are number theoretic
because if you're defining a number
as an equivalence relation,
so you can think, yeah, one
plus one equals two, whatever that means.
Or you can say gluing and then gluing
and then gluing and then gluing.
So you can actually get
an infinity category of these sheaves.
So I recommend anyone looking at like
you want to learn
like some of the best global mathematics
and like learning it
conceptually first
is to look at the sheath interpretation.
You're like, Wait, was Edition
the sheaf, the whole time?
Yeah,
talk about darkroom and mathematics.
I'm just feeding him.
Yeah.
So operations and so,
you know, bless Peter for being
so amazing and coming up with this idea.
It's like, oh,
not only can you put a sheath
on a top, a logical space,
you can put a sheaf on a category.
That's the sort of interesting thing
that I'm into.
So take your idea of operating,
of adding numbers
and just go to the category of numbers.
And then if you start working
categorically, that's already shared
action.
You're in this like higher space
yeah.
So operations with diamonds on diamonds
showing something is a diamond, OK,
it's all just a little rigorous,
but at the end
it gives you such an A in Estheticism
because
I think that, you know, all of this work
should be pulling in everyone.
You need the philosophers.
Make sure
we're asking the right question.
You need the crazy
math people like me to come up with like,
well, I don't know, let's try
like an infinity category.
And then you need, you know,
you need active.
Like, we need people actually, you
working on how do you relate all this?
So you need active efforts,
you need the philosophy
and you need to put everyone together.
Yeah. So in the dark
room, my questions, it's like
at what point was dark?
Like light, you know?
So I think also the darkness is like
maybe a pro finite condition.
The question is,
if we sat in a dark room forever,
would it eventually become light?
You know, and then you bring in time.
So Dark Room is really interesting
and try to think of dark room
and it's impossible non locality.
That's how I would take that problem and
kind of accelerate it just a little bit.
Dark room in terms of a diamond dark room
and change the time interpretation.
Like in all these models, you know, time
is always modeled as a total order.
That's another thing
I would like to hear from your community.
Like, you know, total order
has this like Connect City property
that every to objects in the total order
are comparable.
Why, why do we model time as continuous
and why do you
model time as a total order?
I think
that I think that should be changed
just a little bit and move it
like non hour comedian
quantum mechanics is going to work on
our comedian with a very specific cutoff.
Right the planking.
But I think you should also
be working with non hour comedian time.
So the awesome person to ask you
a question about the dark room.
Please try to think about dark room
like in in
some kind of temporal non-local
eddy of time was everywhere.
I'm really interested in that.
OK, well I make one more
one more comment here.
This is quite early.
You mentioned how a stock
you said it's it takes in categories
not for example sets and connecting
that to what you said about operations.
This might be quite familiar
to a computer scientist
for whom the function
can take in different things.
So we know there's functions
that take in numbers like two plus two,
but then there might be a function
that takes in a large data set
that has a diamond description.
And so computer science and engineering
kind of the application,
it's really easy sometimes to apply
these recursive definitions
of recursion central to computer science.
But you're right,
when you go to the infinite level
that's kind of where the theory builds
beyond any real implementation
of a computer program.
So we're on the bottom
looking up with the computer science
implementation of nested networks.
And then here's the hand
coming from the top down
saying there's a way
to infinitely structure
that and throw a sheath on it
or I don't know.
Oh, see, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, it's like to upgrade a machine.
That's another project I'm working on.
It's like categorically,
you know what I mean? Like
when you know, the
specific definition of stack
is a two sheave, right?
So it's a sheath
that takes values and categories.
That's actually.
And so it's like, yeah, if you move from,
you know, like an output
is a weighted function or something.
If you move from that to the category
of all possible
weighted functions, then
your complexity has just grown
probably like threefold
using the out years.
It no longer needs to be something
singular.
I output it a weighted function, you
know, particular to this distribution.
Why don't you output an actual category?
Yeah.
Here's another great question
from the chart from Stephen.
He wrote, If these category theory
and geometry approaches
enable another multi scale formalism
that treats time differently,
can this approach play nicely with
current multi scale active inference?
Formalisms
sounds
like he summarized our conversation.
Stephen should present.
Yeah, yeah.
Can he tell me a little bit more
about the multi scale active?
I'm see you're right on it.
If you stackify things right,
think of it like this.
Think that, you know, like Daniel was
saying, if every, you know, if every like
think of every network being like a point
in the modular space, do you see?
Then that whole thing was just a point.
And then how do you actually get
from point to point?
So is that the sort of like multi scale
multiclass?
I'm super
into like multi class classification.
You know,
I really like this question. Yes.
Switch it up to like pro finite
if you category five the thing
you're going to get more connections
right then you're then you're working
in like categories of multi class
active inference, not just one.
Why don't we split it up?
Why don't you color it,
call them incarnations and relate them.
If it's a powerful enough category,
you can put a sheath on it,
put a sheet on it
and then start gluing them all together.
And then I think you really have
a multi class shared inference hmm.
Does that make sense to you?
What what a great question.
Do you have any thoughts on that?
On the multi class?
I mean, I think that's what we're saying.
One thought and the way
that we've been talking about multi scale
active inference is like
let's say the brain is the internal state
and the body is external to it.
So then you have the blood brain barrier
and then at the next level out
you have the brain in the body
interacting with the social niche.
And then you can go up
and you can have societies or groups
that are interacting with each other
and it's a debate in active members.
Just the group really have a blanket
or what kind of blanket does it have?
And here we're not going to speak
directly to that, but we can think of,
quote, American society as a point.
It's a point
and then it has internal structure.
But by using that basically
linguistic token,
by saying it is a point, it's
literally one term that you can pass.
Then it abstracts over lower levels.
And I'm
not exactly sure on what is strong enough
to have a sheath or not or what
that enables, but it sounds like it's
making these nested structures
and laterally interacting structures,
making them composable
and kind of compile level
so that we can actively zoom in
and zoom out
or work with guarantees
or proofs
on these types of structures. Mm.
Oh, I love that. Yeah.
And so I encourage everyone
to maybe as a challenge
and Stephen will like this too
when we say like, OK, so thank you
for explaining that for the multiclass.
Yeah, I agree.
Super like all these levels. Yeah.
To reinterpret that because it's always
a boundary condition, right?
Blood brain barrier.
Barrier between me and group vary
between like
collectivity and non collectivity,
things like this, right?
What is a group.
Group action and things like this.
So re-interpret that with a notion
of a pro finite boundary.
I'm very curious
as to what these boundaries are, right?
They're not solid.
They seem to be sort of like,
are they hidden?
So the very concept of a boundary
is a hidden state.
Something that I was playing with
and I was like, you know what?
At what point is the boundary there?
Does that make sense?
It's almost like, you know, boundary
and hidden state is like this darkroom
phenomena that all of a sudden something
turns on a light boom boundaries there.
Right?
So when you have Levon and Fields
talking about like entanglement,
like, you know, a cross boundary is.